- Pour le gouvernement Trudeau,
les cieux ont déjà été
plus cléments. Souvenez-vous
d'il y a quatre ans...
- Sunny ways, guys, sunny ways!
- Le début de mandat de Justin
Trudeau étaient ensoleillé,
même à l'étranger.
(cris)
Mais un autre voyage
en a fait déchanter.
Et la plus grande tempête
restait à venir avec l'affaire
SNC-Lavalin et l'expulsion,
tardive diront certains,
de Jody Wilson Raybould
et Jane Philpott.
Justin Trudeau a perdu
d'autres alliés. Plusieurs de
ces homologues provinciaux ont
été remplacés par des premier
ministres réfractaires
à sa taxe sur le carbone.
L'achat d'un pipeline
n'a pas apaisé les défenseurs
de l'industrie pétrolière
et a irrité bien
des environnementalistes.
Justin Trudeau essaie maintenant
de regagner le coeur
des électeurs en rappelant
son bilan : allocation
canadienne pour enfants,
légalisation de la marijuana,
renégociation de l'ALENA.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU
premier ministre du Canada
- Que ce soit dans le cadre de
l'ALENA, de l'AECG ou du nouveau
Partenariat transpacifique,
nous avons obtenu des résultats
considérables sans jamais
compromettre nos valeurs.
- Évidemment, il ne se vante pas
de l'abandon de sa promesse
de changer le mode de scrutin
ou d'équilibrer le budget
dans un premier mandat.
Mais d'autres se chargent
de le rappeler aux électeurs.
ANDREW SCHEER, chef
Parti conservateur du Canada
- Surprise! Le budget
n'est toujours pas équilibré.
- Quand Andrew Scheer a été élu
à la tête du Parti conservateur
en mai 2017, plusieurs croyaient
que Justin Trudeau était destiné
à décrocher un second mandat.
Le paysage politique a depuis
changé. Difficile de faire
des prévisions sans risquer
de se tromper. Au cours
des derniers mois, Andrew Scheer
n'a pas ménagé ses critiques,
ses attaques.
- Je demande à Justin Trudeau
de démissionner.
- Il veut maintenant insister
sur ce qu'il a à proposer
et multiplie les discours.
Mais l'enjeu de l'avortement
et cette ancienne prise
de position sur le mariage
entre personnes de même sexe
sont récemment revenues
le hanter.
JAGMEET SINGH, chef, NPD
- Ça soulève de grandes
inquiétudes.
- C'est cette déclaration qui
a fait dire au chef du NPD
qu'il ne pourrait pas appuyer
le Parti conservateur,
dans l'éventualité
d'un gouvernement minoritaire.
Comme quoi les néo-démocrates
se résignent déjà à penser
au scénario de représenter
la balance du pouvoir.
(clochette de vélo)
Au fil de départ électoral,
le NPD est en position
plus précaire qu'il y a 4 ans.
En 2015, Thomas Mulcair
semblait avoir le pouvoir
à portée de main.
(applaudissements)
Le rêve lui a glissé entre
les doigts et six mois
plus tard, les militants du NPD
lui montraient la porte.
THOMAS MULCAIR, chef, NPD
10 avril 2016
- On sort d'ici unis.
- Son successeur, Jagmeet Singh,
peine à remplir les coffres
de sa formation politique.
Il a parfois fait preuve
d'une méconnaissance des
positions de son propre parti.
Il a été élu dans une élection
partielle, mais devra maintenant
affronter une plus grande
bataille.
Tout comme lui et Andrew Scheer,
Yves-François Blanchet se lance
dans sa première campagne
en tant que chef. Son parti
a aussi connu sa part d'ennuis.
En février 2018, des déchirement
internes ont incité 7 des 10
députés à claquer la porte
du Bloc québécois.
Mais le départ de leur chef,
Martine Ouellet, après
le verdict sans appel
des membres du Bloc, a permis
au caucus de se ressouder.
MARTINE OUELLET, cheffe démiss.
du Bloc québécois, 11 juin 2018
- Je vous annonce donc
aujourd'hui que je quitterai le
poste de chef du Bloc québécois.
- L'arrivée d'Yves-François
Blanchet a été bien accueillie
par les députés. Rien n'indique
encore que le Parti soit
sur le point de retrouver
des résultats semblables
à ceux d'avant la vague orange,
mais les bloquistes rêvent
quand même de faire des gains.
ÉLIZABETH MAY
cheffe, Parti vert du Canada
- Je suis vraiment bouleversée
par l'idée que les peuples
du Canada et moi-même sont
les propriétaires d'un oléoduc.
- La cheffe des verts, elle,
en sera à sa 4e élection.
Avec l'environnement qui
s'annonce un enjeu central
de la campagne, le parti
se fait davantage remarquer.
Elizabeth May s'oppose vivement
à l'expansion du pipeline
Trans Mountain et a été arrêtée
durant une manifestation.
(applaudissements)
Elle a doublé la députation
de son parti au Parlement,
depuis l'élection d'un deuxième
député vert le printemps
dernier.
♪ ♪ ♪
Maxime Bernier, lui, est encore
seul à la Chambre des communes.
Il a tourné le dos
aux conservateurs qu'il était
passé si près de diriger et
ne les ménage plus.
MAXIME BERNIER
chef, Parti populaire du Canada
- Ce parti est trop corrompu
intellectuellement et moralement
pour être réformé.
- Il multiplie les déclarations
choc sur le multiculturalisme
et les changements climatiques.
- Le CO2 en tant que tel
n'est pas de la pollution.
- Si on se fie aux intentions
de vote, son Parti populaire
n'a pas encore suscité de grand
engouement et joue donc
le tout pour le tout.
Les heures sont comptées.
Les 39 prochains jours
nous diront vers où
le vent va tourner.